well we're getting there we're almost
eleven hundred remember we were just a
thousand so
okay amazing let's analyze okay
so i want i want people to understand
this this move folks
is so deep that i think i'm gonna save
this for one more three thousand
then i might talk about it and people
might actually understand and now
let's skip this for now and let's just
play another game
those of you thinking all right when is
daniel gonna finally get to like
you know 1600s and 2000s and it's an
honor to have so many different people
but
the thing that i want to point out
before i i jump in is that
i'm only doing one of these okay this is
this is gonna be like an opus magnum
you know i'm not gonna do seven speed
runs i'm not gonna do various kinds of
speedruns i've sort of decided to do
this one
speed run and i wanna do it really
really well i wanna do it the best
that i possibly can and it's going to
take a long time for me to get
through the levels and so i want to
target every single
level i know that my audience is very
diverse there's beginners there's
advanced players and
it is a slower one i realize that it's a
bit of a spoof the name um
but just wanted to clarify that so
everybody's on the same page
and we've got sunni sumit 2099 okay
i hope that's not his rating so we're
still going to go e5
um and okay queen f3 so this guy i think
is loading up the scholars mate
bishop c4 drum roll please there we go
and you guys already know that when this
kind of stuff happens
what you want to do is you want to
develop your pieces and simultaneously
prevent these threats
you don't want to go queen e7 you don't
want to go queen f6 just go knight f6
you don't want to pre-move okay when you
see this kind of stuff you don't want to
pre-move
okay so he thinks he's cool right now
and because we're at a slightly more
advanced level my response is to these
kind of kinds of things is going to be a
little bit more advanced
now he's threatening bishop takes f7 so
the knee-jerk response would be queen e7
but
recognize that after bishop takes up
some we've talked about this the queen
is the worst defender because when it's
attacked it has to respond to them
how can we attack the queen such that
after bishop f7 king e7
this queen is going to be overloaded
what move can we make and we've made
this move many times before
in these types of positions it's it's a
typical way to attack the queen in such
positions
we we aren't afraid to play knight t4
now this is a move you have to play if
you if you're
fully you know confident in this type of
position in your calculation
uh and it definitely comes as a surprise
to him
so i will talk through this after the
after the three games in more detail
basically bishop f7 king e7 queen has to
stay on this diagonal which
is very hard to do because this knight
is guarding d5
now those of you who are trying to
practice your visualization if bishop f7
king e7 and queen c4
how do we continue harassing the queen
and forcing it off that diagonal
how do we force that queen off to that
okay we'll talk about that after the
game
beautiful everybody sees it now this is
a big chance for us
because he hasn't developed any of his
pieces it's a golden opportunity
for us to strike while the iron is hot
so how do we rip
open the scene and when i say strike
while the iron sight what i really mean
is opening up the center that is the
gateway to so many different tactics
what does that mean what move does that
actually entail
let's go and i'm i'm making this move
really without any calculation
i'm just striking because i'm absolutely
sure that with a queen on
like this on d3 this is not going to go
over well for him in fact
let's calculate e takes d5 knight takes
d5 is entirely possible but
we have a move that basically wins the
game what do we do
what do we do my favorite question to
ask you
but this is a very simple move and by
this point we've dealt with so many of
these openings
this should kind of be instinctual for
most people and it is bishop f5
very good everybody's seeing it he has
to move his queen we take on c2 and we
win a rook
and we're ahead of development and he's
gotta move his king
lots of bad stuff happening here for
white in fact
um tamak asks a a great question i'm
gonna note this down and i'm gonna
answer this
while we're doing the autopsy after the
game oh whoa
okay all right i think he wants to give
us a check on b5 i think he's attracted
by this check
i can almost guarantee you he's going to
give us this check
but maybe not i mean the fact that he's
thinking tells me he's
realized that something is amiss i'm
afraid
that it is a little bit too late folks
uh this move d5 i've noted it down i
will explain it
how how did i know when to open the
center and when when to develop how do i
know that
tiamak asked that great question i'm
going to try to answer that and there's
no
generalized answer but i'm going to try
to provide some tips okay let's take the
pawn
we're up a full queen the rest is very
simple
one piece of advice i've shared before
that i'd like to repeat when you are up
a full queen
you do not need to worry about defending
every single pawn
so in this position i know a lot of you
are thinking f6 i don't want to play f6
i don't want to weaken this diagonal
all right forget this pawn let him take
it also don't play bishop
d6 because that leaves the knight
exposed so can somebody give me a very
zen move that
just ignore the spawn and keep
developing what does that mean
which move am i having my eye on yeah
bishop c5 very nice giraffe bishop e7
would have been good too
queen d6 would have been a little bit
too
clunky right you're using the queen to
defend upon and as i've said before
try be very careful about using a piece
like the queen to perform a very small
task like defending upon
so this is going to be so much easier
he's won a pawn but we've completed our
development
he's probably going to castle because of
our
central oh all right well this is just
asking for us so what do we do
yeah trav man i could have done that too
uh but i'll talk about that after the
game rookie eight
exactly bishop before instead of bishops
if i'm just noting this down
very good and uh it you know i know that
you know people joke profit and stuff
like
i didn't know that by sacking on e5
we're gonna actually
use that for our benefit by opening the
e file i thought he would castle
but sometimes you know giving up upon
his unforeseen benefits all right we're
going to take this
now this is another pretty instructive
moment i know we're up a queen and it's
completely winning what should we take
with here
what should we take with you and
remember those of you asking questions
which are all great by the way
i'll address every single one of them
after the three games are played
we're going to take with the knight why
why don't we take with the rook with
check because
we already know the phrase the threat is
stronger in the execution here
we are preparing a discovered check a
discover
check is a lot stronger than taking with
the rook and telling our opponent okay
you're gonna have to move your king
because here he has moved his king
but he's moved it from the frying pan
into the fire the king is pinned
well sorry the pawn is pinned it cannot
move so it's not actually defending this
bishop so we can just take it
and you see that the discover check is
one of the strongest tactical assets
that you can have in any position that
doesn't mean it's always good
but in a position like this with a wide
open king you definitely want to set up
a discovery all right
two more games and then i'll talk about
all three of them let's move on to the
next one
very nice game and we're playing with
alireza for russia okay
that's a pretty scary name not gonna lie
if it was if there was an ali
in front of his name i would have gotten
a little bit more scared
okay so let us diversify a little bit
and let's play some other openings we
have been playing the italian
all right well never mind because he's
not letting us do anything so what do we
do in this position
the king is the penny exactly we have to
publish a book of the terminology can
somebody remind me
what move what move do we play against
the philidor we play d4 why do we play
d4 because
by playing d60 a has not developed a
piece b
he's obstructed as bishop both of these
things are serious concessions which
means
that to exploit them we open up the
center another typical situation
do not rush to move this knight we can
just develop because once he takes this
knight this queen is perfectly safe
because he no longer has a knight on b8
to attack our queen with c5 is a very
typical move
for a lot of players in this position
but do not
assume that attacking the queen is just
going to be a naturally good thing we'll
talk about that after the game
but the move c5 is a very classic
mistake in these types of positions
how do we continue our development what
would be the most active
way of now proceeding
and just you know very natural move but
i just want to kind of
help everybody practice your your sort
of sense for where the pieces belong so
to speak exactly bishop c4
the f7 pawn he's probably going to bring
his night out and we're just going to
continue our development we don't need
to move our queen anywhere queen is
perfectly safe in fact
we are trying to provoke the move c5 and
the main issue with that move since he's
thinking
i can talk about this is going to be
that he weakens the d5 square
and that is a central square that you
certainly do not want to weaken
permanently okay let's castle he's
probably going to go knight c6
big deal he's attacking our queen oh we
move the queen
where should we move the queen and here
we've got to be very careful i know that
a lot of people i know it
we're going to see somebody say queen d5
and that's tempting
but be very careful about moving your
queen into too much traffic
queen d5 might allow bishop e6 queen d3
might allow knight e5 and i don't want
to part ways with this bishop
so i'm going to do something here that
some people really you're so lame day
and queen d1 come on man
guindy won and sometimes you have to
retreat that doesn't mean we've done
anything wrong in fact
our position is so incredibly active
and uh we can continue to activate our
pieces
but it's okay to make the occasional
retreating move that doesn't mean
anything so how do we continue
activating our pieces we have a
beautiful outpost
for one of our pieces what piece am i
talking about
we can develop this bishop that's fine
but i'm thinking about a particular
outpost
let's get this knight over to the center
let's get this knight over to the center
look at this beautiful square
we can take the bishop at our leisure
but we're not going to because this
knight is very strong
we're going to try to make him be the
one to take this knight
and i really like the proposal of hidden
king
let's increase our central control by
playing f4 that's not necessarily the
move that i would make
in a game that i would play but i want
to show people how to attack like this
okay
so we haven't completed our development
which is not a situation that i like
particularly
and here is a good example of when to
maneuver now
we look at this bishop for a second okay
we can put it on e3
is it really doing anything on e3 we
could be getting more bang for our buck
where should the bishop go and this will
look like a very awkward move initially
but it's it's a maneuver right we make
an awkward move but then the bishop
maneuvers to a good square
boom zeraf that's the right idea i don't
want to play b3
because that weakens the long diagonal
but the idea is the same
we're getting our bishop look at this
we're reading his mind because
we're not thinking about the immediate
square we're thinking about the
long-term square
now we get the bishop to the long
diagonal and we have an extra knight
and this is not a coincidence i've told
i've said this before when we play like
this
we piss our opponent off i mean we annoy
him okay
what should we do he's attacking our our
knight
we already know that there are two main
methods of trying to convert extra
material
believe it or not we can actually make a
move that doesn't involve moving the
knight
this is one of those things that you
just got to kind of think about because
we have so many active pieces
gotta start thinking about how to how to
set threats bingo the wrath is on fire
queen d4 attacking the pawn
if he plays bishop f6 then we get a
chance to trade everything in one fell
swoop okay it
allows us to deliver checkmate um how do
i find
a move like 15 queen d4 how do you know
to look for it
i'll talk about that after the game let
me just open up the window and we see
different openings we see the french now
the opening that i really like to play
against the french
to illustrate conceptual i wanted to say
conceptual concepts that's how i know
it's 10 p.m
is the advance french and the advanced
french causes trouble to a lot of french
players
because it leads to a close position now
this is a conceptual mistake we talked
about this he is attacking
the tip of the pawn chain rather than
the base of the pawn chain
that is wrong in this case and in most
cases because
what happens when you attack the tip of
the pawn chain very often
is that look at this square on e5 now it
is a square that we can occupy with a
knight now it is an outpost that he has
granted us
and in addition we still have nice
central control
now one very important thing we don't
need to get our knight to e5 immediately
it's just a square that's available to
us at some future point for now we're
just going to develop our pieces
right there's no need to to rush with
anything we can just complete our
development at our leisure
and he always is going to have to watch
for this now he's playing with some
serious fire
in addition to allowing us this square
85 he has opened up the e-file
which means that there's a very natural
move that we can play now thank you jay
kushner for the sub
knight g5 is a knight g5 is a very good
move but let's play in a more
almost stereotypical fashion not very
creative but very strong i mean it's
hard to defend the spare there we go
guess what move now this allows now this
knight
has landed on f8 to defend the pawn
so what move now should be considered
and there's a couple of interesting
things eric the red unfortunately not
70s at the moment but i'll talk about
that knight g5 okay but
knight g5 doesn't attack the pawn let's
play in a very methodical fashion
i want to go knight e5 okay
i'm gonna go 95. the problem with 95 is
you might take it
so i want to get this bishop out of d6 i
want to trade it
so what we're going to do and this is a
move i'm going to make and explain later
is go bishop g5 there's two principle
reasons for this first of all i'm
developing my bishop to a very active
square
good second of all and this is a typical
french idea i'm not pulling this out of
my behind
bishop h4 bishop g3 is going to invite
the trade of bishops
once the bishops are traded our knight
is going to have free passage to the e5
square this is another maneuver
okay and he's done it our work for us
this kind of play once again yields
positive benefits even without us trying
to
complete our idea okay knight g6 how do
we continue
how do we continue and there's many good
moves here
in literature there's a phrase kill your
darlings
which means sometimes you have to get
rid of what you love so i would very
seriously consider taking with the
knight and then the bishop to force his
king out but
because i love this knight too much i
don't want to kill our darlings let's go
bishop takes g6
and instead of grabbing this pawn with a
knight greedily let's try to take this
pond with something else
what else can we take this pawn with or
at least try to take this bond with
and that in combination with the night
is going to yield tremendous
tremendous attacking benefits let's go
here i've told you guys this at the very
beginning of our speedrun the knight and
the queen
is the strongest pair of attackers on
the chessboard there is no
pair of two pieces not even a queen and
a rook in some regards
that are as strong of attackers as the
queen and the knight
because of their ability to control
squares because of their ability to
defend each other
because of their ability to deliver
checkmate
all right and that's nice how that word
coincided with him playing king f8
okay we've got a lot to unpack we're not
going to take too long on this i want to
do at least one more set of games
but let's jump in to the analysis okay
you know things are going well here all
right first game
sumi 2099 i know people are excited to
look at this game but we'll get there
now the move knight d4
let's unpack this for a second bishop f7
king e7
one thing to watch out for sometimes
people forget that the e6 square is
undefended
when the e6 square is undefended i know
this looks ridiculous right now but this
could be checkmate okay
so make sure that the e6 square is
actually defended when you allow bishop
takes f7
he has to play queen c4 to keep his
queen protecting and the move b5
is a fitting representation of what's
going on here because the queen the poor
queen has to leave the bishop it has no
more squares
diagonal all are protected king f7 we're
up a piece
now i am chess man asked about knight a5
which would be also relatively effective
now the problem this knight is
undefended
i've emphasized the importance of
undefended pieces many times
you've got to be very careful about that
what can white do here to save material
you can give a check
and trade the bishop for the night so in
addition to the night being centralized
it is also defended by a pawn
which greatly raises its appeal the way
i would think about this is in relation
to the queen
right the queen is the easiest piece to
attack so when our opponent is developed
as queen early
we can often get away with opening up
the center before we have completed our
development
because our opponent has now completed
his and we already have developed two
pieces
right and he's only developed one and
the queen is like an anti-developed
piece that's actually a negative
net negative so when our opponent has
his queen positioned so awkwardly on a
square like d3
that's what really sets off the alarm
bells right it's that awkward
positioning of the queen
okay what happens if we open up the
center you calculate a little bit and
you see the bishop f5 wins i know that's
not a good answer
but at least hopefully you know that can
provide some context
and then the only other important
moments right ignoring the pawn we're up
a queen
we don't need to do that we can just
develop our bishop
the check on before would be fine but it
would allow him to block it with a pawn
so this would not be anything
spectacular we could come back to c5
here that would be fine
but after knight takes e5 it might allow
him to support the knight with d4
okay the rest was very simple knight
takes e3 preparing the discovery and
winning another piece and he resigned
okay next game
he played a philidor so we played d4
one tidbit that i shared earlier those
of you um who are here
uh who have not been here when i talked
about this for the first time
but a little trivia question for those
of you who have what is the interesting
tidbit about the philidor and this is
unconfirmed
but i'm about 95 sure that this is the
case what is the interesting tidbit i
shared about the philidor
the last time one of our opponents
played it
yes philidor and j news is correct
philidor never played it himself
andre philidor 18th century chess
pioneer never
actually played the philidor i think he
just talked about it in his
seminal chess work but that's just an
interesting little factoid about
the way that chess openings are
sometimes named and uh
philadelphia is not a terrible opening
okay and and i want to
take a second to talk about something
that people don't always realize
there's a bunch of these openings and
one opening is called the 5000 bit
opening that gem jim just
just played holy smokes incredible
incredible support 70 gifted subs over
the course of the week and now
unbelievable stuff thank you so much for
another
tremendous bit drop the absolute
legend the vampire the penny
appreciate it uh and um
the philidor yeah gem jim before jam jam
rudely distracted me from talking about
the philadelphia with this
5000 bits but i appreciate it
yeah there's a misconception that
openings like the philadelphia openings
like
even d5 are are in some sense absolutely
terrible and lose
or even the move queen e7 which my first
coach used to play against me and
drive me crazy because it's this is
actually a very hard move to refute
these openings are not losing they're
not terrible
they're just dubious and the most that
white can do if black plays well is get
a
solid edge but nothing more than that so
you have to temper your expectations if
your opponent plays something like this
do not go crazy trying to win the game
in five moves
it's a lot better to adhere to basic
principles and get a small advantage
than to go wild and try to win the game
quickly that's exactly what people who
play these types of openings once
okay so d4 opening up the center
developing our pieces developing pieces
dropping our queen back to d1 so just to
recap if we go queen d5
um our queen you know enters the highway
and we don't want that right
it gets into too much trouble if we go
queen d3
we allow 95 and he roots out our bishop
um so we dropped the queen back which is
totally fine
knight t5 and zerath asks in some
positions i try to put a knight on an
outpost but my opponent almost
always has something like 97 to
challenge the knight and i lose the
outpost
any suggestions on how to get the
outpost anyways well that's a good
question right
and the fact of the matter is knight t5
is not truly an outpost because
we can envision a scenario where he
drops his knight away from c6
from c6 and then plays c6 to kick the
knight away
the way that you want to think about
outposts is in terms of trade-offs right
you want to envision all the scenarios
where he gets rid of the outpost one of
them
is the scenario in which he captures the
knight on t5
but the fact of the matter is what do we
gain in return for the night outpost
well we get the bishop
now on an outpost which is a pretty darn
good outpost maybe not as good as the
night
wouldn't you say this is pretty good we
have the possibility of winning his pawn
structure
we have the possibility of the bishops
cooperating so when you think of chess
advantages you want to think of them in
a transformational sense you don't want
to think of anything as a permanent
advantage you want to think of something
okay
this is an outpost what happens if my
opponent tries to trade that outpost can
i replace
that advantage with something else and
that something else can be as
as ethereal as time if it takes your
opponent four moves to do something
that in and of itself is already a
reason to do that thing in the first
place
i don't know if i'm making sense but
time is a huge commodity it's like the
money of chess
okay um and and something takes your
opponent three or four moves to do you
can use those three or four moves to
lift a rook up
and then transmute that into um into
uh into an attack and i have a really
good example of that that i just showed
one of my students earlier today
i'm sorry to take so many details let's
finish this game and then i'll show it
very quickly
here we transfer our bishop to the long
diagonal where it can sort of cooperate
with the other bishop
and of course he blunders his knight he
sort of he was intent on playing this
move
and so we unwittingly also prevented it
then drop our bishop back
and then we create the threat of queen
take g7
this as you guys know is called a
battery when we stack a bishop and even
on top of each other it's one of the
exceptions
to what i was talking about about not
putting the queen in too much traffic
here
this is more effective than putting the
bishop first and the queen second
uh because we're actually threatening
checkmate okay i
there were some questions that i missed
let me just look over the chat for a
second
um will there ever be a female chess
player like beth harmon well
i would say that there already was uh
and her name was judith pogar
and um people don't always realize this
but polgar
there's two things to say here now i
finished queen's gambit two days ago so
i have some more thoughts
polgar i think at the highest yeah was
world number eight she was i think a
grandmaster
and grandmaster not women's gm but
actual grand master
at 13 and she was you know
one of the most feared players on the
international chess circuit her style
was incredibly tactical she was blowing
people off the board she was blowing
2700s off the board regularly and um
and just to round off the beth harmon
conversation
pogar uh my my long time coach left
sahis
who now lives in israel grand master
obviously russian grand master
was also one of the strongest players in
the world in the 80s and 90s and knows
polgar very well
and and he told me that people and
people hated playing judith pogar
because of her style
she she was 24 incredible opening
preparation
um and and just blowing people off the
board um and as i understand it
beth harmon's main main move was when he
four although
against vorgov well some stuff was
changed up
uh but in any way well thank you tyler
okay um
in any case this is how this game ended
let me make a very quick detour
to show one thing before our last game
before our second
speed run segment um i don't know what
the orthodox gambit is just give me a
second guys i need to find this game
there's just one moment from a game
that illustrates the concept of buying
yourself time
literally okay and um
this is a pretty high level example so
you know i'm not going to spend too long
on it
but it's important trust me we're good
um so we can go back to this scene
and as you guys can see this is a game
between spassky and the fm
fm geller yes jen uh
geller yes or sarah one's favorite
player
uh was playing black here yes exactly
yes precisely uh okay so
it is white to play this was a close
sicilian this was not silberg it was uh
quarter-final of the candidates uh so
this was spassky's world championship
run anyways he's playing white here
it's white to play and let's very
quickly understand what's going on now
this is one of those situations where
in the closed situation often white
attacks on the king side
and he tries to get his queen to h4
those of you who play the grand prix
attack this is kind of a sister opening
uh to the grand prix i guess this is a
classical game
now the problem is that black also has
something to say about that he's
attacking on on the queen side
right he has the a file he's got this
fiance bishop and if white just
willy-nilly plays g4
here's going to be the problem black's
going to take on a1 now he's just going
to snap that pawn off on g4
exposing the attack on the queen and
getting rid of this incredibly valuable
knight
so here's what spassky does and i won't
give this to anybody as a problem just
be it
trust me i'll give you guys a chance to
exercise this i just want to show this
for now
he goes rook c1 which is a move that
wouldn't occur to most people because
he's voluntarily giving up that af why
is he giving up
an entire file that he seems to be
fighting for
not only is he giving up the file geller
thank you very much boris vasilyevich
i'm going to get my rook to a2 and then
i'm going to get my queen to a6 and he
gets both of his pieces on the a file
here's the reason he plays this move the
only purpose of this move is to buy
himself time
okay he's setting up this art this fort
on c2 consider this like an army fort
this army ford is staffed with soldiers
and he knows that there are not enough
soldiers to last forever he knows that
eventually black is going to get to the
c2 pawn
once he takes that pawn the dam breaks
the water floods in
but he's buying himself enough time to
get such an attack
going on the king's side that by the
time geller takes that c2 pawn and he
tries trust me i'll show you
spassky is going to be well on the way
to checkmating him look at what happens
queen a6
spassky very methodically but very
quickly geller
guess where he's going he's going a3
he's going after the pawn
but by the time he gets there and he has
finally gotten there
that is when spassky goes quinn h4 and
if he finally takes the pawn
here perhaps you guys can tell me how
white wins the game
okay maybe i'm taking a long time to
talk about something very obvious but i
think this is a very deep concept brooke
takes f6 and mate is inevitable
geller must move the rook away spassky
does this anyway
there's a lot of tactics here he sacks
another knight this is completely
winning for black because
um the pieces just pour in and the
attack is completely unstoppable queen
takes g6 is coming
i know that i'm going fast through the
details just trust me on this white is
completely crushing
so that is the purpose of why i'm
showing you this because
you have to be very flexible in chess
you have to understand that time is
in and of itself a very valuable
commodity completely waiting for white
yes
thank you for the correction nicola okay
back to the speed run and back to the
last game
because i know everybody's anxious for
me to play more okay
um so that's actually one of my favorite
games now in this game he played a
french
just to uh recap f6 is i i mean i think
this is a mistake
uh because whoops because c5 here
is the main move attacking the base of
the bond chain we've already faced this
once
e takes f6 now we've got a weak square
on e5 but we don't occupy it immediately
we don't rush
we don't rush because he can take our
knight and um
aaron nimsovich who i've referenced
several times he calls the situation
like a visit to the dentist right
you're letting black visit the dentist
and fill his cavity like the pawn on e5
is is a filling
you don't want to let your opponent feel
fill his cavities right you want to put
a piece on a weak square
not necessarily a pawn a bit of a
not an example i think anybody needed
especially people like eating ice cream
right now thank you scruffy roden but
you get the point i think it's actually
a pretty effective example
okay um rookie well this i i didn't
think of this analogy that was nemesis
okay i really i recused myself from this
thank you nephew for uh
gifting two tier one subs to the
community tyler mandel and sultan
okay so rookie one attacking upon
everything we did here was very obvious
up until this moment
this is the e5 square that we want to
occupy this is the bishop
that is defending it we ask ourselves
the next logical question codex thank
you so much
and since and i can't even keep up with
these subs two months from send fish
codex with eight months thank you so
much this square and e5 is defend we
want to get rid of the bishop
how do we get rid of the bishop well we
have a bishop of our own can we put it
on f4
no we cannot can we prepare the mood
bishop f4 we can
but the problem with something like this
is going to be this ruins our pawn
structure near our king i don't want
that
so what we do and nephew himself
something we get our bishop from g5
all the way back to g3 okay and i can
show you a million examples
where where something like this happens
i can pull out examples from some of my
own games i think
um i'm not sure if i can remember i
think i can remember one
from the top of my head but
i mean this is this is very typical
again i'm not trying to to sell to play
myself off as
oh i have all these games to show you
this is truly very typical
and here we go well
not exactly the same thing um but but
you get the points
um and and let me just go back to the
chest-based scene
this is a game ah chess space is not
made for streaming so
i have to keep changing stuff uh but but
it's worth it thank you for being so
patient
all right
okay we're good this is my game against
varukovian from the 2011 u.s
championship it was a french it was a
different line of the french
but the same thing happened the e5
square is weakened
and um bishop g5
bishop h4 and bishop g3
so and the point of this i've already
taken his bishop but i'm still
transferring my bishop to reinforce my
control
over that e5 square so this is stuff
again that actually happens
you know in real life um back to
the speedrun quote unquote speedrun
here we do the same thing we get our
bishop there instead he loses his
patience
he allows our knight to get t5 and then
he goes knight g6
and here of course as i explained during
the game
we're trying to take on g6 t9k as i
explained we're trying to treat his
bishop
in order to free up the c5 square um so
we're trying to take the spawn on g6 and
uh deliver checkmate on f7 which he
misses he has ways of defending
with rook h6 and to the point of
flexibility we don't stubbornly get our
bishop back to g3 how do we change our
plans dynamically
in the context of attacking this pawn
bishop g5 is correct
he's completely busted because he can't
move his rook he's just lost here i mean
he's going to lose a lot of pieces
what happens if they move their bishop
back after we move our bishop back well
that then then we succeed right if he
doesn't do this
and if he goes whatever empty move and
if he goes bishop b7 we've succeeded
right we can now get our knight to e5
scot-free
i'm not actually saying that this is the
best idea but i want people to
understand that i'm not doing everything
because it's the best i'm trying to
illustrate crea
instructive ideas so people can file
file them away and apply them
that doesn't mean i personally would
always do this kind of stuff seth morgan
io thank you for the tier one
why not knight c3 and then ip5 well
knight c3 would be pretty easy to
prevent that's really the only reason
but this would be very
very uh very good plan as well
this idea is just harder to prevent
because this pathway is
is just impossible to stop